Public Sénat vous propose de revoir cet
été des extraits du débat au Sénat en
séance autour du contreversé projet de
loi sur le renseignement un texte
destiné à renforcer les moyens et les
techniques des services de renseignement
français au lendemain des attentats de
janvier dernier mais un texte jugé aussi
trop intrusif par ces détracteurs qui
estime qu'il porte atteinte à la vie
privée le Sénat a largement amendé ce
projet de loi en augmentant les pouvoirs
de la Commission de contrôle et en
limitant le recours à certaines
techniques de renseignement une position
de consensus a ensuite été trouvée en
commission mixte paritaire entre les
députés et les sénateurs c'est
aujourd'hui la version finale de ce
projet de loi sur le renseignement que
je vous propose de revoir sur notre
antenne lors de sa dernière lecture au
Sénat monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'ordre du du jour appelle
l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire chargé
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
relatif au renseignement dans la
discussion générale la parole est
d'abord à Monsieur Philippe Bas
rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission mixte
paritaire
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président de la
Commission des Affaires étrangères et de
la défense madame la présidente de la
commission des lois et bien sûr monsieur
le ministre chers
collègues le Sénat a abordé la
discussion de ce texte avec une ambition
en
faire une loi
républicaine inscrivant pour la première
fois la politique française du
renseignement dans le cadre de notre
État de
droit tout au long de nos débats nous
avons chercher à rejoindre la grande
tradition du Sénat républicain garant de
la protection des libertés publi
refusant toute législation
d'exception choisissant au contraire
d'inscrire la mise en œuvre des
techniques modernes de renseignement
dans le droit commun du ôle qui
s'applique à toute autorité publique
dans l'exercice de ses prérogative au
service de l'intérêt
général sont en effet en jeu d'un côté
la protection de la vie humaine et la
poursuite d'intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation et de l'autre le respect de la
vie privée le secret des correspondance
la
liberté depuis 1789 nous nous admettons
que tout droit toute liberté même les
plus inviolables les plus sacrés
connaissent des bornes mais nous
exigeons cependant que ces bornes soient
fixées par la loi et par elle seule et
nous demandons encore à la loi quand
elle fixe ses Bordes de n'interdire que
les actions nuisibles à la société comme
l'exige l'article 5 de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du Citoyen or
qu'y a-t-il de plus nuisible à la
société que le terrorisme et le crime
organisé encore faut-il que les bornes
que nous posons soient strictement
limité à ce qui est indispensable à la
réalisation des objectifs d'intérêt
général que nous confions à l'état c'est
tout le sens du travail accomp par le
Sénat et ce travail a été
pleinement reconnu
par la commission mixte paritaire qui
s'est réunie le 16 juin dernier
l'exigence de nous conformer au principe
posés par la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen a été notre
obsession tout au long de nos
délibération nous étions jusqu'alors
dans le non drroit nous voulons rentrer
dans le droit nous avons voulu créer le
droit je souhaite que nous y soyons
parvenus
nous nous soumettrons bien sûr au
contrôle vigilant du Conseil
constitutionnel sur tous les points sur
lesquels le Sénat a entendu inscrire son
empreinte de défenseur des libertés
comme rapporteur de ce texte je serais
heureux monsieur le Président du
Sénat que vous puissiez porter nos choix
de le Conseil constitutionnel vousmême
afin que celui-ci puisse se prononcer
sur l'ensemble de nos apports et
vérifier que les objectifs que nous
avons poursuivi ont bien été
atteint si ce texte est adopté par notre
assemblée et demain par l'Assemblée
nationale il s'inscrira pleinement dans
le respect du principe de
l'égalité
en ce qui concerne les techniques de
renseignement nous avons posé dans
l'article 1er de la loi et la commission
mixte paritaire l'a
maintenu les principes de
légalité que devrait suivre l'autorité
pour mettre en œuvre les techniques de
renseignement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les décisions de mise en œuvre
des techniques de renseignement de
devront procéder d'une autorité ayant
compétence pour le faire cela veut dire
que la procédure suivie devra être
conforme à la loi si un service de
renseignement met en œuvre une technique
de renseignement sans passer par la
procédure légale il y aura illégalité
cette illégalité devra être sanctionnée
cela veut dire aussi que les décisions
prises devront respecter les missions
confiées à chaque service qui les met en
l'œuvre et ces missions sont défines
dans la loi pas question qu'un service
facee à la place d'un autre ce que cet
autre service serait habilité à faire
cela veut dire aussi que les techniques
de renseignement qui seront mis en uvre
devront l'être en justifiant la réalité
des menaces des risques des enjeux
invoqués pour obtenir l'autorisation
d'appliquer ces techniques de
renseignement cela veut dire aussi qu'à
chaque fois qu'une technique de
renseignement sera utilisée elle devra
répondre aux intérêts fondamentaux de la
nation qui sont énumérées par cette loi
et surtout cela veut dire que les
atteintes porté au respect de la vie
privée ou aux garanties apporté à
l'exercice de certains mandats ou de
certaines professions devront être
proportionné au motifs invoqués
l'arsenal juridique mis à la disposition
de la Commission nationale de contrôle
des techniques de renseignement à la
suite de nos
délibération garanti que le contrôle des
techniques de renseignement sera pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
République pleinement
assurée la commission mixte paritaire
est
parvenue un
accord sur tous les points sauf fin
qui a fait éruption au cours de nos
débats les échanges préparatoires avec
le président rapporteur de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale ont
été
excellents la collaboration que nous
avons eu pour faire aboutir cette
commission mixte paritaire je tiens à le
dire a été
féconde l'adoption de cette loi va faire
progresser l'État de
droit le projet de loi n'instaure
nullement de surveillance de masse il
fait exactement le contraire il ne
prévoit que des surveillances ciblées et
compte tenu de ce que j'ai rappelé à
l'instant toute mesure de renseignement
qui ne seraiit pas ciblé tomberait sous
le coup du principe de l'égalité dont
nous avons défini le
contenu il faut à chaque fois viser avec
précision les éléments de fait et les
finalités qui justifieront la mise en
œuvre des techniques de renseignement
dans le respect du principe de
proportionnalité le respect de la
proportionnalité fait partie de la
légalité les apport du Sénat tendant à
renforcer les pouvoirs de contrôle et
les garanties d'indépendance de la
Commission nationale de contrôle ont été
intégralement repris par la commission
mixte paritaire il en est de même de
nombreux autres apports qui visent tous
à conforter la constitutionnalité du
projet de loi en assurant le respect de
nos droits et de nos libertés en
assurant aussi l'effectivité du contrôle
juridictionnel que notre texte permettra
de mettre en
œuvre le compromis trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire me permet aujourd'hui de
vous présenter un texte en réalité très
proche de celui que vous avez
adopté les principes de de la politique
publique de renseignement sont désormais
clair le cadre légal
existe le compromis qui a été trouvé sur
le renseignement pénitentiaire je tiens
à le souligner n'interdit pas la mise en
œuvre de techniqu de renseignement en
prison au contraire il permet de mettre
en œuvre ces techniques de renseignement
dans les conditions du droit commun si
bien que un détenu ne sera pas davantage
à l'abri que n'importe lequel de nos
citoyens dont la surveillance serait
rendu
nécessaire en matière de
renseignement la procédure
d'autorisation des technique a également
été maintenu par la commission mixte
paritaire dans les termes que le Sénat
avait voté nous avons souhaité que le
premier ministre et les ministres
concernés puissent choisir des
représentant de l'autorité publique
librement autour d'eux mais qu'on ne
fonctionnarise pas cette fonction qui
doit rester une fonction de
responsabilité auprès de l'autorité
exécutive nous avons demander que la
mise en œuvre des
renouvellements d'autorisation soit
justifié de manière particulière cette
disposition est maintenue par la
commission mixte paritaire nous avons
voulu limiter les finalité permettant la
mise en œuvre de la procédure d'urgence
absolue et clarifier le recours à la
procédure d'urgence opérationnelle ces
dispositions ont été reprises par la
commission mixte paritaire nous avons
voulu préciser le régime spécifique
applicable aux professions protégées là
aussi le texte qui vous est soumis
aujourd'hui est fidèle à votre vote
précédent la solution du Sénat a
également été validée s'agissant du
point de départ du délai de conservation
des informations recueillies dans la
mise en œuvre des techniques de
renseignement ce point de départ c'est
le recueil de l'information ça n'est pas
le moment où cette information est
transcrite car sinon cela laisserait à
l'autorité administrative toute
l'attitude pour décider du point de
départ du délai alors que ce point de
départ doit être
objectif je voudrais
dire d'entrée de jeu que je suis tout à
fait favorable à l'AM que dépose le
gouvernement et qui répond d'ailleurs au
souhait que j'avais moi-même exprimé en
commission mixte paritaire pour que nous
ne modifions pas le régime de
surveillance des citoyens étrangers de
passage en France sur le territoire
national un seul régime juridique doit
s'appliquer quelle que soit la
nationalité des personnes qui se
trouvent sur notre
sol je crois que cet amendement se
heurtait de toute façon à de solides
interrogations du point de vue de sa
constitutionnalité nous avons également
maintenu un certain nombre d'apports du
Sénat sur la composition de la
Commission nationale de contrôle 9
membres et non point 13 sur la
différenciation des missions des membres
avec une formation restreinte une
formation pligniaire des pouvoirs
propres de certains des membres de la
commission qui sont tous magistr
ou conseiller d'État de sorte que le le
système que nous avons retenu est
intégralement préservé de même que les
pouvoirs de la Commission de contrôle
nous avons voulu une commission de
contrôle avec de très larges pouvoirs
nous avons même créé un délit d'entrave
quand une administration s'opposait à
l'exercice de ces pouvoirs nous avons
voulu que la Commission soit
indépendante et quel est les moyens de
son indépendance nous avons voulu que le
président de la commission nomme
lui-même mais non pas le premier
ministre ses collaborateurs tous ces
points ont été intégralement préservés
par le travail de la commission mixte
paritaire et surtout le point le plus
crucial pour nous tous c'était d'assurer
la réalité du contrôle juridictionnel
des
autorisations de mise en œuvre des
techniques de renseignement or le texte
don nous étions saisis prévoyait bien la
possibilité d'un recours devant le
Conseil d'État mais dans des conditions
tellement restrictive que l'on pouvait
craindre que ce recours n'ait jamais
lieu nous avons maintenant un dispositif
qui permet à seuls trois membres de la
commission de contrôle de saisir le
Conseil d'État c'est-à-dire dans des
conditions très souples nous savons au
moment où nous voterons ce texte que le
contrôle du Conseil d'État jouera
effectivement et nous pouvons
naturellement être confiant de la
manière dont le Conseil d'État exercera
ce contrôle il a mainte fois dans son
histoire prouver son sa qualité de
défenseur des libertés publiques gajon
qui le prouvera de nouveau dans
l'application de cette loi sur le
renseignement quant aux techniques de
recueil de renseignement je ne reviens
pas sur nos débats nous avons apporté de
nombreuses garanties supplémentaires
technique par technique celles-ci ont
intégralement été préservées de manière
à ce qu'on nabuse pas de ces techniques
dans des cadres qui ne seront pas
strictement ce que la loi
prévoit il y a également un certain
nombre de disposition sur le fichier
judiciaire des auteurs d'infraction
terroriste à chaque fois il faudra pour
être inscrit dans ce fichier une
décision du juge ou du procureur si bien
que nous arrivons à un texte qui en
vérité devrait satisfaire pleinement le
Sénat tantil ressemble au texte que nous
avons adopté il y a quelques temps je
voudrais souligner également le
renforcement des prérogatives de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement que préside notre collègue
le Premier ministre Jean-Pierre rafarin
et à la suite des amendements qu'il a
proposé le contrôle de la dééation
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement va se trouver élargi au
service de renseignement appartenant à
ce qu'on appelle couramment le second
cercle pas les services de renseignement
qui sont inscrits dans la loi mais ceux
qui viendront s'ajouter par décret du
Premier ministre de même la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement recevra
des statistiques détaillées relative à
la mise en œuvre des techniques de
renseignement par finalité et par
technique de sorte que si nous
constatons euh un recours exagéré à
certaines techniques ou dans des
conditions qui ne nous satisfont pas
nous pourrons saisir le gouvernement de
la nécessité en tout cas de
l'opportunité de modifier les pratiques
ou les textes
enfin la commission mixte paritaire a
bien sûr maintenu la clause de
rendez-vous que nous avons tenu à
ajouter au texte ce texte comporte
beaucoup de dispositions évidemment
sensibles il faut en pouvoir en faire le
bilan nous pourrons le faire à la
lumière des travaux de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement mais
aussi à la lumière du rapport annuel de
la Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement si bien je
crois que si ce texte est adopté il sera
tout à fait exemplaire de notre volonté
d'inscrire pleinement dans la tradition
de l'État de droit français la mise en
œuvre de ces mesures de police
administrative que sont les techniques
de renseignement contemporaine c'est la
raison pour laquelle je tiens cet
après-midi à exprimer ma satisfaction
des résultats de la commission mixte
paritaire et naturellement à vous
inviter à donner une large majorité à
l'adoption de ce texte merci le monsieur
le
Président la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard casenuve ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le Président
Monsieur monsieur le Président
rapporteur cher Philippe Bas Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est tenu le mardi 16
juin s'est conclu par un accord qui nous
permet de nous réunir aujourd'hui pour
soumettre à votre examen et je l'espère
à votre approbation le texte issu des
travaux réalisés par les représentants
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
lorsque j'ai présenté ce texte devant le
Sénat d'abord devant la commission des
lois et celle de la défense et des
Affaires étrangères puis dans
l'hémicycle j'avais formulé le vœu que
dans la grande tradition républicaine le
Sénat puisse jouer tout son rôle pour
consolider juridiquement le texte
présenté par le gouvernement et amendé
par les députés en première lecture non
seulement ce vœu a été exaucé grâce au
travail remarquable conduit par les
sénateurs sous l'autorité du président
rapporteur Philippe B mais je tiens
aussi à souligner combien la version du
texte qui vous est soumis pour
approbation à l'issue de la commission
mixte par itire est inspiré des travaux
que vous avez vous-même réalisés durant
la première lecture lors de l'examen du
projet de loi vous avez forgé toute une
architecture de contrôle reposant sur
une idée simple et que je trouve pour ma
part incontestable plus une technique du
renseignement est intrusive et plus elle
suppose des garanties procédurales
renforcées le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire reprend très
précisément cette doctrine ce qui se
matérialise par des amendements
incorporés au texte final reprenant ceux
adopté par le
Sénat je pourrais citer par exemple le
délai de conservation des interceptions
de sécurité courant à partir du recueil
et non de la première exploitation de la
sisine automatique du Conseil d'État
pour autoriser une intrusion
domiciliaire après un avis négatif de la
sncttr ou encore les restructions à
l'usage du IMS catcher ces amendements
provenant du Sénat ont été pour
l'essentiel conservés il en existe
d'autres je sais que le Sénat fera ce
travail important d'inventaire qui
démontre une fois de plus l'ampleur de
la contribution de la Haute Assemblée
dans la rédaction de la loi j'invite
d'ailleurs chaque observateur de la vie
politique à s'y référer tant les travaux
sont incontestables même sil n'est pas
l'usage de faire de longs discours à
l'occasion de ces lectures j'aimerais
préciser la position du Gouvernement sur
certains amendements adoptés en
commission mixte paritaire commission
qui réunit les députés et les sénateurs
et à laquelle vous le savez n'assiste
pas le gouvernement tout d'abord vous
avez adopté deux amendements ayant pour
effet que les techniques mises en œuvre
sur le territoire national à l'égard de
ressortissants étrangers non résidents
n'est pas à faire l'objet d'un contrôle
de la CNC il s'agit d'une proposition
émanant du travail du Parlement le
Gouvernement est défavorable je dirais
même très défavorable à cette
proposition pour des raisons de nature
constitutionnelle vous connaissez la
position constante du gouvernement
chaque mesure doit être appréhendée à
l'ône des garantie juridique dont elle
est assortie la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel est en effet très
restrictive quant au possibilité
d'instituer des différences de
traitement au détriment des étrangers
même non résidant dans l'application de
la loi française sur le territoire
national en particulier il est difficile
d'admettre de telles différences lors ce
qui est en jeu le droit à la protection
de la vie privée c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement vous propose de
revenir sur ces dispositions en adoptant
des amendements de suppression et
s'engage à convaincre les députés
d'adopter des amendements identiques
pour ne pas obérer la réussite de la
lecture des conclusions de cette CMP par
ailleurs deux amendements de précision
vous sont soumis pour clarifier les
rédaction issue de la commission mixte
paritaire naturellement le gouvernement
a apporté son aval aux amendements
déposé par les rapporteurs qui
permettent de fluidifier la rédaction
issue de la commission mixte paritaire
j'en arrive à une dernière
disposition sur laquelle le gouvernement
ne dépose pas d'amendement mais souhaite
préciser l'interprétation qu'il se fait
du texte et l'application qu'il en aura
la CMP a souhaité rétablir une
disposition issue de l'Assemblée
nationale relative à l'échange
d'information entre les services du
renseignement et entre les services des
autres administrations d'autres part je
tiens à préciser et je souhaite que cela
soit retenu au contendu de nos travaux
que ces dispositions seront mises en
œuvre dans le strict respect des
exigences de proportionnalité pour une
finalité déterminée au profit de
servicees limininativement énuméré et
dans le respect des missions des
services par exemple les services
réalisent des signalements au cas
d'allocation familial de bénéficiire de
prestations sociales parti se rendent
sur un théâtre de guerre et ne répondant
donc plus au critères de résidence sur
le territoire national nécessaire à
l'attribution de ces allocations afin
qu'il soit mis un terme au versement et
d'éviter ainsi de donner une source de
financement à des activités terroristes
c'est dans ce type de cas très précis
très circonstanciés avec des garanties
préservées que cette mesure sera mise en
œuvre voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les précisions que je
souhaitais formuler en remerciant une
fois de plus le président teur Philippe
B le Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
rafarin et l'ensemble des sénateurs pour
la qualité du travail qu'ils ont
accompli tout au long de la discussion
de ce texte comme si il s'y était engagé
le président de la République
transmettra au Conseil constitutionnel
le projet de loi au terme de l'examen
parlementaire comme le lui autorise la
Constitution ce qui permettra encore de
renforcer toutes les garanties autour de
ce texte je vous remercie encore une
fois d'avoir contribué par votre
contribution à ces débats à donner un
cadre à l'activité des services de
renseignement dans un contexte où les
progrès de la technologie ont fait leur
œuvre cadres qui jusqu'à présent
n'avaient pas été donnés à ces services
et qui les conduira désormais à
intervenir sous l'effet d'un double
contrôle celui d'abord d'une commission
administrative indépendante dont la
composition et les modalités de
fonctionnement garantiront un haut
niveau de contrôle je veux parler de la
CN CTR contrôle juridictionnel qui
pourra aller jusqu'à la saisine du juge
pénal lorsqu'il sera constaté par le
Conseil d'État ou même par la CNCT que
dans le cadre de la mobilisation d'une
technique de renseignement une
infraction pénale aura été commise
contrôle parlementaire renforcé puisque
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement dispose désormais d'une
possibilité d'effectuer de puissant
contrôle sur l'activité des services de
renseignement ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant cette législature au moment où
cette délégation parlementaire a été
instituée c'est dire la volonté qui est
celle du gouvernement et de l'ensemble
de la représentation nationale de faire
en sorte que l'activité des services de
renseignement permett notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit de la lutte contre le
terrorisme de protéger résolument et
fermement les Français contre des
risques dont nous avons vu à quel point
lorsqu'ils se traduisent par des actes
ils peuvent être meurtriés et conduire
la République à devoir affronter des
défis puisque ces actes sappent la
République à ses fondements et par
ailleurs nous souhaitons aussi que cette
loi fasse rentrer notre pays dans la
liste des démocraties dont les services
sont les plus contrôlés de façon
exigeante et rigoureuse pour la
contribution qui a été la vôtre à
l'élaboration de ce texte je veux au nom
du gouvernement vous renouveler mes très
sincères remerciements
merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Sueur pour 14
minutes monsieur le le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
à ceux qui s'interrogent sur le rôle du
Sénat il en est toujours je
conseillerai la lecture de ce texte de
projet de loi tel qu'il est arrivé au
Sénat et tel qu'il a été voté au Sénat
et je conseillerai de
surcroix la lecture du texte issu de la
Commission mixte
paritaire chacun pourra voir que le
Sénat a pesé lourdement dans l'écriture
du texte et que la commission mixte
paritaire a repris un très grand nombre
des apports du Sénat il faut le dire
puisque cela est vrai et que chacun
pourra le constater c'est dire que à mon
tour je souscris aux conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire à une
exception notable qui a déjà été notée
et sur laquelle je
reviendrai un point
positif a été obtenu suite au débat du
Sénat c'est que le ministère de la
Justice soit exclu de la liste des
organismes de renseignement ayant la
faculté de mettre en œuvre des
techniques
intrusives cela était contraire aux
missions du ministère de la
Justice et il était très nécessaire
qu'il y ait là-dessus une parfaite
clarté ça ne veut pas dire que le
renseignement pénitentiare n'est pas
utile il est nécessaire nous l'avons dit
je le
redis toutefois il est aussi nécessaire
de ne pas mélanger les fonctions il ne
revient pas à un surveillant
pénitentiaire d'être par ailleurs un
agent de renseignement sans cela tout
est confondu il n'y a plus de clarté
mais il faut que les services de
renseignement puissent œuvrer dans le
domaine pénitentiaire et il faut qu'il y
ait des liens à cet égard entre ces
services
et les services pénitentiaires et
d'ailleurs je voulais dire à notre
rapporteur au fond Monsieur Philippe Bas
que nous avions trouvé une rédaction ici
au Sénat qui permettait de faire la
clarté sur ces relations donc nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir en
d'autres circonstances mais l'essentiel
était de préserver une lecture très
claire du projet de loi à cet
égard je voulais souligner un certain
nombre de points importants en dehors de
celui-là d'abord grâce au Sénat et grâce
à l'amendement du groupe socialiste on
me permettra de le dire la vie privée se
trouve clairement défini dans le texte
dans toutes ces
composantes secret des correspondances
protection des données personnelles
inviolabilité du
domicile deuxièmement il est positif que
l'adjectif majeur et là je remercie
l'assemblée nationale soit revenu je
vais faire quelques peine peut-être à
Monsieur le Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
rafarin mais je pense qu'il est
préférable s'agissant de la politique
étrangère des intérêts industriels de
parler d'intérêt majeur et surtout pour
les intérêts économiques auquels vous
êtes à juste titre très attaché cher
Jean-Pierre rafarin je voulais dire
qu'il me paraissait quand même
impossible de parler des intérêts
économiques en général sans aucune
précision donc cela est arrivé au terme
de la CMP et c'est une bonne chose pour
ce qui est des délais de conservation
des données il y a eu un
compromis un compromis est un
compromis toutefois le Sénat a pesé dans
ce
compromis puisque les dates seront
appréciées par rapport au recueil des
informations et non par rapport à leur
exploitation d'autre part pour ce qui
est des données crypté il n'y avait pas
dans le texte avant l'arrivée du texte
au Sénat de délai ceci faisait peser sur
le texte un lourd risque
d'inconstitutionnalité c'est pourquoi il
est heureux qu'au terme de la commission
mixte paritaire un délai est été
instauré pour ce qui est de la
commission de contrôle le Sénat a fait
en sorte que ses pouvoirs soient
clairement étendus je prendrai plusieurs
exemples d'abord Monsieur Philippe ba
dit trois membres de la commission sur
ne pourront saisir en toute circonstance
le Conseil d'État c'est
important
deuxièmement nous avons obtenu que
monsieur le ministre de la
Défense dise au Sénat et d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
avez conforté cette réponse que y
compris le pncd cette plateforme dont
nous avons parlé donnera lieu aux
possibilités de contrôle de la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
techniques de renseignement c'est un
point qui a été dit qui engage le
gouvernement et c'est une bonne
chose enfin toujours s'agissant du
contrôle je veux insister sur le fait
que nous avons pu et mon groupe y a
aussi contribué pour une deuxème fois je
me permets de le souligner inscrire on
n'est jamais mieux servi que par
soi-même en effet Monsieur mard inscrire
dans le texte que le contrôle de la
Commission sur l'ensemble des données d'
d'interception sera je cite direct
complet
permanent ce qui veut dire que face à
certaines interrogations que nous avons
bien
entendu sur le fait que contrairement à
une situation antérieure les données
pourraient être dispersées en divers
lieux et bien il y aura un droit reconnu
par la loi aux membres de la commission
de disposer de ces données de manière
complète
exhaustive directe sans intermédiaire et
permanente c'est-à-dire à toute heure du
jour et de la nuit 365 jours par an
c'est
important s'agissant des techniques dont
on a parlé anti
humsicatur et s'agissant des
algorithmes il a été bien précisé les
limites dans lesquelles l'accès à ces
techniques était possible et notamment
le fait que cela devait avoir pour seule
finalité la lutte contre le
terrorisme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire qu'il était nécessaire de
surveiller un certain nombre de sites si
on dit que ce n'est pas nécessaire alors
disons clairement qu'on ne veut pas
lutter contre cont le terrorisme mais si
on veut lutter contre le terrorisme on
ne peut pas ne pas contrôler qui qui se
connecte sur des sites qui font
l'apologie du terrorisme qui présentent
des horreurs qui présentent des appels
au meurtrre et bien entendu il y aura
des gens qui se seront connectés par
hasard et bien il ne s'agit pas de les
mettre en cause
aucunement mais il est nécessaire de
procéder à des investigations
sous le contrôle de la Commission et
sous toutes les garanties en respectant
toutes les garanties inscrites dans le
texte si l'on veut lutter contre le
terrorisme pour ce qui est du fichier
national des auteurs d'infraction
terroriste je me réjouis que l'on ait
repris la proposition émanant de
l'Assemblée nationale selon laquelle
l'inscription sur ce fichier doit être
le fruit ou l'effet plutôt d'une
décision positive d'une autorité
judiciaire pour ce qui est de la
protection des magistrats des avocats
des journalistes et des
parlementaires la commission mixte
paritaire a permis une avancée
supplémentaire puisqu'il est clairement
écrit dans la loi
désormais que ces personnes ne pour
pouront faire l'objet d'une surveillance
à raison soit de leur profession soit de
leur mandat le Sénat avait beaucoup
œuvré en ce sens c'est maintenant acté
dans la loi d'autre part je veux
insister fortement sur le fait que
toutes les mesures qui sont dans le
texte sans aucune exception sont des
mesures qui procèdent du
ciblage de l'intentionnalité clairement
manifestée et jamais je dis bien jamais
du contrôle de masse
c'est-à-dire du fait de capter des
milliards et des milliards
d'informations au détriment des droits
des personnes nous sommes contre la
captation massive
d'information nous voulons que toute
technique soit mise en œuvre dans un but
affiché
déterminé contrôl
avec les garanties nécessaires de telle
manière qu'il n'y ait aucun détournement
de la procédure donc cela est clair et
cela figure noir sur blanc dans le texte
je terminerai en disant moi aussi qu'il
y a eu un amendement qui a été adopté à
une voix de majorité par la commission
mixte paritaire relative à la situation
des personnes étrangères Pr ente pour un
court
séjour cet amendement contre lequel pour
ma part j'ai voté mais je ne suis pas le
seul puisqueun grand nombre de sénateurs
ont voté contre cet amendement présente
des risques constitutionnels comme cela
a été dit et plus que des risques
d'ailleurs il est clairement
inconstitutionnel vous l'avez dit
monsieur le ministre il est contraire au
principe
d'égalité et il pose problème tant sur
le fond que pour ce qui est de sa
procédure d'adoption puisque il n'est
pas souhaitable vous le savez bien que
des amendements fussent adoptés en
commission mixte paritaire alors qu'ils
n'ont donné lieu à aucun débat ni à
l'Assemblée nationale ni au Sénat pour
ces raisons je vous indique et je dis
ici très clairement que le groupe
socialiste votera sans réserve
l'amendement numéro 8 du gouvernement
monsieur rafarin je vous rassure
qui a pour effet de
supprimer cet alinéa qui a été introduit
à une voix de majorité lors de la
commission mixte paritaire mes chers
collègues pour la première fois il
existera dans ce pays une loi encadrant
les services de renseignement l'action
des services de
renseignement ce n'est pas neutre cela
n'existe pas et ce qui est quelque peu
paradoxal c'est que au moment où on fait
une loi pour encadrer par la loi
l'action des services de
renseignement on vient nous dire que
nous porter que nous portons atteinte
aux libertés c'est quelque peu paradoxal
mais surtout je tiens je me permets
d'inciter certains auteurs de telle ou
telle
tribune à lire le texte parce que il est
tout à fait vrai que ce texte pose des
problèmes il est tout à fait clair que
ce texte posait des problèmes auquel
nous avons
répondu il est tout à fait clair que
c'est un sujet sensible mais je lis
parfois des déclarations des écrits qui
témoignent d'une absence de connaissance
de ce que le texte
dit de ce qu'il dispose or quand on lit
les choses dans le détail on voit mes
chers collègues et sans aucune
autosatisfaction d'aucune sorte on
reparlera du sujet dans 5 ans et sans
doute bien avant que nous nous sommes
efforcés d'atteindre le meilleur
équilibre possible et sans doute il y
a-t-il encore des améliorations la
perfection n'est pas de ce monde des
améliorations apporté mais nous avons
cherché à atteindre en toute bonne foi
le meilleur équilibre entre la sécurité
nécessaire car il faut lutter contre
l'horreur du terrorisme et la protection
de nos libertés des données personnelles
de la vie privée car nous pouvons le
redire ici la plus grande victoire des
terroristes serait de nous faire
renoncer à nos libertés je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame bembassa
pour 6
minutes bonjour monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues 67
sénateurs dont 10 membres du groupe
écologiste se sont opposés à ce texte
comment peut-on encore adopté
aujourd'hui des lois rappelant celle de
George Bush qui plusit après les
scandales que nous avons connu et les
révélations d'Edward
Snowden qu'avons-nous fait pour mériter
ce traitement antidémocratique que nous
laisserons un héritage aux exécutifs à
venir qui pourrait se révéler moins
scrupuleux que celui
d'aujourd'hui pourquoi cette surdité aux
arguments fondé de ceux qui s'oppose à
ce PGL cette cécité face au danger qu'il
présente avez-vous cédé au lobby des
services de renseignement qui n'ont pas
jusqu'ici démontré leur grande dextérité
à déjouer les attentats dont notre pays
a été la cible est-ce avec les
métadonnées qu'ils y parviendront quand
on sait qu'ils n'ont pas pu suivre des
délinquants en processus de
radicalisation religieuse malgré les
informations transmises par des
responsables des lieux de détention où
il s'était trouvé
incarcérés certes il fallait un texte
pour mettre fin aux dérives aux
pratiques non encadrées voir illégales
des services de renseignement mais pas
un texte comme celui dont nous débattons
à nouveau et qui met cette fois
légalement en péril nos
libertés personne ici ne peut être taxé
de laxisme ou d'un conséquen face au
terrorisme mais il faut j'en suis
certaine lui opposer une résistance
efficace et consciente sans jamais
brader nos libertés premièrees cible
justement des obscurantistes qui nous
visent je voudrais partager avec vous
mes chers collègues les propos d'Edward
Snowden lanceur d'alerte Silanis qui
raisonne aujourd'hui d'une manière bien
singulière je cite le fait de dire qu'on
se fiche de la vie privée parce qu'on a
rien à cacher revient à dire qu'on se
fiche de la liberté d'expression parce
qu'on a rien à dire le champ
d'application de la loi devait pour être
acceptable être davantage limité et
définir de manière précise et
restrictive les motifs d'intérêt public
justifiant la mise en œuvre des
activités de
renseignement à la lecture du texte de
la commission mixte paritaire qui
reprend dans son ensemble la rédaction
élaborée par notre Haute Assemblée forcé
de constater qu'on en est loin au nom de
la sécurité et même s'il s'agit de lutte
contre le terrorisme on ne peut pas
placer entre les mains de
l'administration les pouvoirs
normalement dévolu aux
juges pour prévenir d'éventuelles
conséquences fâcheuses les pouvoirs de
la Commission nationale des contrôles de
techniqu de renseignement aurait dû être
renforcé nous avions d'ailleurs
préconiser qu'elle puisse lorsqu'on lui
demande l'autorisation de mettre en
œuvre une mesure vérifier sans délai
sans restriction que celle-ci est
parfaitement légale proportionnée et
subsidiaire non seulement ce n'est pas
le cas dans le texte qui nous est soumis
aujourd'hui mais une disposition a été
ajoutée à l'initiative du rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale comme l'ont dit
certains collègues autorisant le Premier
ministre à avoir recours aux technique
de renseignement sans avis préalable de
la CNCT lorsque leur mise en œuvre ne
concerne ni un Français ni un résident
habituel en
France le Conseil constitutionnel aurait
probablement eu à examiner ces
dispositions contraire au principe
d'égalité devant la loi et nous nous Ré
de la volonté du gouvernement de la
supprimer je propose
que toute
personne majeure en phase avancée ou
terminale incurable d'une maladie
provoquant une souffrance physique
psychique insupportable et qui ne peut
plus être apaisé puisse demander dans
des conditions précises et sous contrôle
de plusieurs médecins à bénéficier d'une
assistance médicale pour vivre sa vie
dans la dignité jusqu'à la fin
après le mariage pour tous c'est l'une
des réformes de société sur laquelle on
attendait François Hollande le droit à
une aide active à mourir en proposant
une assistance médicale pour vivre sa
vie dans la dignité jusqu'à la fin le
candidat Hollande a délibérément choisi
une formulation ambigue où jamais il ne
prononce le mot
euthanasie des mots à la loi le
président avance avec prudence après 2
ans de concertation nationale il confie
la rédaction d'une proposition de loi à
deux députés Alain clè et Jean
Leonetti une proposition de loi
consensuelle qui reprend et précise la
première loi Leonetti de 2005 sans aller
jusqu'à
l'euthanasie selon un sondage pourtant
90 % des Français y sont favorables pour
les personnes en fin de vie ce nouveau
texte répond-t-il vraiment attentes des
Français va-t-il assez loin de la
promesse de campagne à la loi le
consensus sera difficile à
trouver pourquoi un nouveau texte et
bien parce que malheureusement dans la
pratique on constate encore qu'on meurt
mal en France on meurt mal avec deux
revendications légitimes de nos
concitoyens c'est je ne suis pas entendu
en fin de vie et on continue à souffrir
dans les derniers jours et les dernières
heures de la
vie bonjour bonjour
Docteur comment ça va ce matin et ben ce
matin ça va très bien ouis les douleurs
ici là toujours vous les sentez un petit
peu quand même à 78 ans
c'est la deuxème fois qu'Angèle est en
soin palliatif au CHU de
Montpellier atteinte d'un cancer
incurable elle sait sa mort proche son
seul souhait finir ses jours sans
souffrir moi ma propr mort je l'envie je
je sais que je mourrai mais je veux pas
mourir en souffrant voilà je sais que je
vais mourir un de ses jours parce que ça
ça est au point où on est au palliatif
pour la douleur et tout ça c'est qu'il y
a pas d'autre chose grande chose à faire
mais on n pas la souffrance moi je
comprends les gens quand ils souffrent
trop ils se jettent sous le train parce
que c'est des souffrance qu'on peut pas
tenir quand on fait les soins palliatifs
après au contraire ça ça soulage ça ça
guérit pas mais ça enlève la douleur moi
c'est ce que je veux je veux
mourir sans souffrir
voilà pour soulager les souffrances dans
ce centre de soins palliatif on utilise
des techniques à la pointe comme la
sédation une sorte d'anesthésie plus ou
moins profonde pour apaiser le patient
cette technique sédation c'est quand on
est en échec effectivement sur un
symptôme particulièrement insupportable
pour le patient donc
avec certains médicaments enfin
notamment le midazolam on l'utilise pour
entraîner un sommeil d'une profondeur
qui va dépendre du patient et des
patients qui préfèent rester é un petit
peu éveillé d'autres qui ne veulent pas
être du tout réveillés donc ça on adapte
la dose et qu'on peut faire de manière
transitoire par exemple pour un symptôme
comme le dispné qui peut être parfois
transitoire euh ou pour de manière on
peut également faire cette céation de
manière continue si le patient
effectivement ne désire plus du tout
être réveillé la loi de 2015 veut
démocratiser la sédation profonde et
continue c'est-à-dire l'endormissement
profond du patient dont la mort est
imminente pour lui éviter de souffrir
lors de ces dernières
heures ce que on veut vraiment c'est
endormir le patient pour pas qu'il qu'il
subisse ce qu'il est en train de vivre
mais on ne veut pas précipiter sa mort
simplement il faut qu'il soit quand même
un peu plus serein par rapport à ce
queil est en train de vivre on met des
fois des sédation comme ça sur des
choses cataclysmiques on voit et ça on a
on a eu à le faire il y a pas très
longtemps un patient qui s'est vidé de
son sang euh et qui le voyait et qui
était conscient et c'était terrible et
bon donc là on l'a endormi et il est
parti non pas de notre endormissement
mais du fait qu'il était en train de se
vider sur d'une hémorragie sur lequelle
on pouvait pas intervenir si vous
voulez si dans ce genre d'unité
spécialisée les médecins maîtrisent
cette technique ce n'est pas le cas dans
d'autres services hospitaliers comme aux
urgences ou dans les services
d'oncologie où le taux de mortalité est
élevé la sédation profonde est continue
y est peu utilisé l'objectif de la loi
est donc de la
généraliser ce droit qu'on appelle le
droit à la sédation en phase terminale
est un droit qui paraît légitime
aujourd'hui c'est un devoir des médecins
de le mettre en place ça n'est pas le
cas malheureusement dans 15 à 20 % des
cas et bien il faut que ça devienne un
droit et peut-être que la vraie
modification de la loi c'est de dire
avant c'était un devoir de la société et
un devoir des du corps médical et des
soignants de faire en sorte qu'on ne
souffre pas en fin de vie et bien
désormais ça devient un droit du malade
de ne pas souffrir lorsque la mort mort
approche et que les médicaments
habituelle n'arrive pas à calmer la
souffrance la nouvelle loi précise les
cas où cette sédation profonde et
continue doit
s'appliquer premier cas le patient est
conscient il est atteint d'une tion
grave et incurable son pronostic vital
est engagé et l'arrêt des traitements va
provoquer sa mort à court
terme autre possibilité le patient est
inconscient pour éviter l'acharnement
thérapeutique le médecin décide
d'arrêter les traitements il peut dans
ce cas aussi demander une sédation
profonde et
continue en encadrant la sédation
profonde et continue les auteurs de la
loi voulaient être
consensuel mais au Sénat cette
proposition va cristalliser les
oppositions autour de la question de
l'eutthanasie tris camp vont s'affronter
il y a d'un côté les rapporteurs de la
proposition du texte et le gouvernement
ils vont soutenir l'idée d'une sédation
profonde et
continue ce texte est ce et pour ceux
qui vont mourir par pour ceux qui
veulent mourir ce qui élimine très
clairement
euh le le débat sur l'euthanasie et le
suicide assisté non pas que ce débat ne
soit pas important voire capital mais
quelque part ce n'était pas l'esprit de
la loi sur laquelle nous
discutions d'autres une partie des
sénateurs républicains s'opposent à
toute évolution juridique pour eux le
texte va trop loin en inscrivant la
sédation profonde et continue dans la
loi le législateur proposerait en
réalité une euthanasie
déguisée la sédation profonde continue
jusqu'au décès vous voyez bien on liait
la sédation et le décès et là ça nous a
apparu pas pour moi seulement mais pour
un certain nombre d'entre nous comme
quelque chose qui sortait du dispositif
consensuel de la loi Leonetti et qu'il y
ait le décès à l'acte de ces nation donc
on engageait on
s'engageait sur dans
l'engrenage sur le chemin du suicide
assister et
l'euthanasie enfin il y a les sénateurs
qui estiment que cette sédation profonde
et continue n'est pas suffisante ils
veulent inscrire dans la loi le droit à
l'euthanasie nous voulions répondre à
deux demandes différentes qui sont de de
nature différentes d'une part le droit à
un suicide médicalement assister
c'est-à-dire que on abrège la fin de vie
un peu avant le terme qui est imminent
et puis donc c'est le suicide assister
et puis d'autres part il y a des
personnes qui réclament lorsqu'elles
sont dans un état désespéré la
possibilité d'une
euthanasie premier affrontement en
séance autour de l'article 3 sur la
sédation profonde et
continue les opposants à cette pratique
lance l'offensif contre les rapporteurs
du texte depuis le départ un certain
nombre d'entre nous pensons que la loi
les deti se suivisait à elle-même et que
et que la loi actuelle qui est pour
certains un prolongement ou un éclairage
n'est pas un prolongement ou un
éclairage c'est une rupture il est
incontestable que cet article 3 et la
porte ouverte à une euthanasie que vous
ne voulez pas dénommer comme telle
les sénateurs proposent d'enlever du
texte l'expression continue jusqu'au
décès pour éviter tout amalgame avec
l'euthanasie pour Alain Milon le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales qui est aussi médecin c'est un
coup porté au principe même de la loi
bon cette proposition de loi ne ne tue
pas on n'est pas là pour tuer on n'est
pas là pour faire deeuthanasie on est là
pour accompagner des malades en fin de
vie alors la la proposition que que nous
fait notre collègue de Lège sur le fait
de mettre une sédation profonde et de
supprimer continue jusqu'au décès ok
pourquoi pas ça veut dire que la
sédation n'est pas continue elle si elle
n'est pas continue elle est discontinue
et si elle est discontinue ça veut dire
qu'on doit l'arrêter de temps en temps
pourquoi continue plaçons-nous quand
même dans la vraie vie si j'ose dire
comment imaginer que chez ces patients
qui souffrent atrocement on va
interrompre la sédation pour dialoguer
avec eux sur l'opportunité de quoi de
continuer c'est impensable et vraiment
ceux qui ont porté cet amendement sont
très éloignés de de la vraie vie c'est
le cas de le dire je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement 59 rectifié qui est
pour l'amendement est adopté une partie
des républicains obtient gain de cause
le mot continue est tiré du texte la
séance est suspendue dans les couloirs
les esprits s'échauffent entre les deux
camps non moi je suis pas content de
toute façon je suis pas content de ce
débat depuis le début parce qu'il y a
ceux qui sont honnêtes il y a ceux qui n
qui nous prépareis désolé bon mais pas à
travers ça ça a été disons de manière un
peu habile sans doute par certains de
vouloir faire comprendre que la sédation
profonde et continue était très proche
de l'euthanasie alors ça n'est pas vrai
puisque l'euthanasie elle est faite un
moment avant qu'on soit dans ces
situations là c'està-dire avant que la
personne soit vraiment en fin de vie
c'est-à-dire avec une espérance de vie à
court terme et ne supportant plus les
souffrances qu'elle subit donc ça n'est
pas du tout une euthanasie c'est
simplement une possibilité d'aider à
mourir sans avoir les
souffrances l'autre offensive contre le
texte viendra cette fois des
proethanazies
sénateurs de toute tendance politique
réuni autour de Jean-Luc Roméo président
de laadmd une association proethanasie
convoque la presse il y a dans chaque
groupe des parlementaires qui ont déposé
des amendements allant dans le sens de
ce que souhaite de ce que souhaite la
DMD c'est-à-dire qu'il y a enfin une loi
qui permette à chacun de choisir c'est
pas une loi spécialement pour
l'eutthanasie une loi qui permette de
comment dire de
choisir il compte inscrire dans le texte
un droit à une aide active à
mourir bah cé important justement que
certains sénateurs et de toute tendance
parce que c'est ça qui était important
puissent dire que eux ils souhaitaent
clairement qu'on aille à la légalisation
de l'euthanasie et du su d'assister
comme les Français le le le demande dans
tous les sondages depuis 20 ou 30
ans le soir même en séance les h
sénateurs déposent tous un amendement
pour légaliser
l'euthanasie cet amendement propose
d'instaurer un droit à bénéficier d'une
véritable aide actif pour mourir pour
les personnes majeures il répond à une
très forte demande de la population il
vise à instaurer l'assistance
médicalisée active à mourir dans des
conditions strictes chacun doit se voir
ainsi reconnaître le droit d'aborder sa
fin de vie dans le respect des principes
de liberté d'égalité
fraternité des amendements rejetés mais
l'objectif est atteint le débat sur
l'eutthanasie a été mis sur la
table nous voulions poser ce débat
c'est-à-dire d'une loi qui irait plus
loin donc l'idée était d'expliquer
pourquoi cette loi nous somble trop
timide et pourquoi nous voulions aller
plus loin et pourquoi du coup nous avons
tous déposé un amendement très très
voisin pour essayer d'avancer alors
l'ambigué qu'il faudrait lever c'est que
ce texte n'était pas fait pour ceux qui
sont en fin de vie et qui qui veulent
mourir ce texte a été fait pour les
malades en fin de vie qui vont mourir
donc évidemment ce texte ne recouvrait
que très imparfaitement les demandes que
nous
avions l'autre point de clivage du texte
ce sont les directives anticipées un
document où l'on inscrit ce que l'on
souhaite pour sa fin de vie
edit a écrit les siennes les bénévoolle
au centre d'écoute de l'ADMD
l'association au droit à mourir dans la
dignité compte tenu de mon
âge je refuse toute
réanimation alimentation forcée
artificielle lorsque la mort paraît
inévitable mettre sur papier ce qu'elle
veut pour sa fin de vie une évidence
pour elle après la mort d'une de ses
amis en 1987 j'ai assisté à la mort
terrifiante d'une amie qui avait une
clérose latérale amotrophique la maladie
de Charco et qui mourait dans des
conditions d'étouffement qui n'en
finissait plus j'ai appelé le docteur
c'était un dimanche on a fait venir SOS
médecin et j'ai dit au médecin écoutez
elle est en fin de vie regardez est en
train de mourir en S tout for il me dit
oui elle va mourir il me dit oui elle va
mourir je lu dit mais docteur faites
quelque chose pour que ça aille plus
vite il m'a répondu mais madame je ne
peux rien faire d'ailleurs elle n'a rien
demandé et je ne peux rien faire alors
ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir et j'ai
très vite rédigé des directives de
volonté comméd dit aujourd'hui il n'y a
que 2,5 % des Français qui ont rédigé
leurs directives
anticipées Sophie oui j'ai eu la visite
ce matin d'une nos adhérante et elle est
venue porter ses directives anticipées
alors j'ai regard pour Sophie
responsable des directives à la DMD si
aussi peu de gens les ont écrites c'est
qu'elles sont méconnues mais pas
seulement il s'agit de de de confronter
cette idée de mort de déchéance de de
fin de vie euh c'est pas enfin en tant
qu'être humain on n' pas envie de de
confronter ça n'est-ce pas euh ensuite
souvent les personnes ne savent pas
parler de leur fin de
vie aujourd'hui les directives
anticipées ne s'imposent pas aux
médecins elles peuvent être rédigées sur
papier libre et sont valables 3
ans la loi de 2015 pré prvoit de les
rendre contraignantes pour le médecin de
créer un modèle officiel qui sera
intégré dans un registre nationale et
leur validité ne sera plus
limitée au Sénat pas de rassemblement
non plus sur les directives anticipées
un bras de fer s'engage entre les
défenseurs du texte et le noyau dur des
sénateurs les républicains ces derniers
estiment que le disposit
va trop loin ils vont de nouveau réussir
un coup de force et faire enlever du
texte le caractère contraignant des
directives anticipées et par conséquent
nous proposons une autre rédaction
qui indique que le médecin prend en
compte les directives anticipées mais
qu'elle ne s'impose pas à lui c'est
effectivement une différence majeure
entre nous le médecin est là pour
prendre en compte les directives
anticipées mais il doit doit garder son
appréciation et son
jugement merci Monsieur delè la question
de cette directive c'était doivent-elles
engager les médecins ou pas doit-on
laisser une marge de manœuvre au médecin
qui peut aussi avoir des éléments
d'appréciation de façon collégiale
notamment pour Marie sol Touren la
ministre de la Santé cette nouvelle
manœuvre vise surtout à vider la loi de
son sens je donne un avis défavorable
parce que demand que les directives
anticipées ne s'imposent pas au médecin
et ne s'inscrit pas là non plus dans la
perspective porté par cette proposition
de loi merci madame la ministre qui est
pour qui est
contre il est adopté s'il y a des
directives anticipées elles doivent à
notre avis elles doivent être appliquées
par le médecin qui est présent alors que
là tel que c'est on retombe comme
auparavant et ça veut dire qu'elles ne
sont pas opposables donc le médecin peut
faire ce qu'il
veut directives anticipées non
contraignantes sédation profonde mais
non continue le texte qui devait être
celui du consensus a été vidé de son
contenu détricoté par un petit groupe de
sénateur républicain mobilisé et qui a
su donner de la voix face à la
Commission et au gouver
là on est on est effectivement dans un
texte qui s'est éloigné progressivement
non seulement du texte de 2015 mais qui
en partie a remis en cause le texte de
2005 donc je crois que la première des
choses à faire c'est s'appuyer sur le
texte 2005 dont tout le monde y compris
au Sénat et y compris les adversaires de
la loi 2015 disent qu'elle est très bien
donc ne touchons pas à la loi
2005 une dernière question va être
débattue celle du droit d'accès aux
soins palliatifs chaque année en France
ils ne sont que 100000 personnes à en
bénéficier pourtant les besoins sont
trois fois plus
importants bonjour bonjour bonjour vous
ça vaou ça veut dire quoi que ça
va les murs de cette chambre Thierry les
connaî par cœur il est cloué dans son
lit depuis 1 an on lui a découvert une
maladie orpheline incurable il y a 4 ans
depuis son état se dégrade pour soulager
ses douleurs une équipe de soins
palliatif vient régulièrement à son
domicile ils me soulage ils me soulag
dans tout ils sont bien ils sont
toujours là ils réglent tous les
problèmes quand on en a ils sont très
bien ils sont très bien je suis bien
entouré bon ben voilà comment tu le
trouves moralement il a dit qu'ilit pas
moral Fatima est infirmière c'est elle
qui gère l'équipe de soins palliatif à
domicile elle vient voir Thierry
régulièrement en fonction de ses besoins
l'occasion pour elle de faire le point
avec les aides soignants sur l'évolution
de l'état de santé de Thierry
alors notre rôle c'est d'être en lien
avec les professionnels du domicile de
réfléchir avec eux comment maintenir
améliorer soutenir la présence du
patient chez lui c'est toi qui a le
dossier des patients hospitalisés chez
eux Fatima en suit une
quarantaine son équipe de soins
palliatif est financée par l'agence
régionale de santé mais clairement elle
manque de
moyens d'accord on ne peut pas dire que
c'est suffisant en terme de moyens hein
puisque nous sommes sur un bassin très
important un bassin géographique très
important et nous couvrons un nombre
deune population de plus de 625000
habitants donc on est une équipe
quasiment toute à temps partiel
et nous avons de plus en plus de
demandes de la part des professionnels
de santé des institutions et des
familles mais mises en lien par les
professionnels de santé ce qui signifie
que nous sommes de plus en plus
sollicité pour cette aide au maintien à
domicile en France des réseaux à
domicile comme celui de Fatima sont
rares la loi Leonetti de 2005 devait
pourtant les développer tout comme les
unités de soins palliatifs dans les
hôpitaux aujourd'hui très inégalitaires
sur le territoire s'il y en a beaucoup
dans les grandes agglomérations elles ne
sont pas suffisantes dans les zones
rurales
idem pour les unités de soins palliatifs
qui se déplac dans les services des
hôpitaux les unités
mobiles un manque criant dénoncé par les
sénateurs les républicains qui demandent
au gouvernement d'inscrire l'égalité
d'accès au soins palliatifs dans ce
nouveau texte je pense que ceux qui sont
pour ce texteux qui le porte ne peuvent
pas ne pas entendre ce cri le cri des
territoires qui sont injustement traités
avec ces kirriel de malades qui ne
peuvent pas avoir accès aux soins
palliatifs alors que leur état devrait
le leur permettre et qu'ils en souffre
un des soucis du texte et d'aujourd'hui
et de demain d'ailleurs c'est que on se
refuse en France avoir une politique
massive d'investissement en matière de
culture palliative en matière de soins
palliatif c'est là qui le problème et
surtout vous savez que 20 % de nos
concitoyens ont accès à ces soins
palliatif 80 % n'y ont pas accès et ces
soins palliatifs c'est le privilège de
quelques territoires la plupart de nos
territoires n'y ont pas accès et je
considérais avec d'autres que le
problème le plus urgent c'était pas
tellement de faire une nouvelle loi
c'était d'abord d'essayer de traiter ces
problèmes très
concrets les rpporteurs et le
Gouvernement partage ce constat mais
estime que cette question doit être
traitée dans le cadre du financement de
la santé ministre dis il faut développer
les soix palliatifs c'est quand même
avant tout un problème purement
financier et ça ça se décide dans le
PLFSS d's dans le budget de financement
de la sécurité sociale donc PLFSS ce
genre d'amendement réapparaissent ça au
contraire est tout à fait d'accord
personnellement j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer réexpliquer mais ils n'ont pas
voulu suivre au PLFSS et bien nous
réclamerons et nous inscrirons les
moyens financiers nécessaires pour que
le développement des soins palliatifs se
fasse sur l'ensemble du territoire mais
l'argument des rapporteurs ne convin pas
les autres groupes politiques se Rall au
républicains alors au risque de
surprendre moi je pense que c'était
plutôt bien comme amendement et il me
semblait alors que je défends une
position différente pour le reste du
texte je me sentais tout à l'heure un
petit peu là-dessus je pense que le
préalable c'est les soins palliatifs
pour tous je m'aperçois avec
stupéfaction que ça pose un problème la
parole est à Madame David je vais vous
étonner à mon tour mais je suis sur la
même position que vient de défendre ma
collègue Corine bouchou la déclaration
d'intention était là elle était ferme et
c'était des soins palliatifs pour tous
sur tout le
territoire s'il suffisait d'inscrire les
choses dans la loi lorsqu'elles doivent
aller de soi pour que les choses se
réalisent ce seraitel tellement simple
j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure que je
présenterai que je proposerai la semaine
prochaine à un comité de pilotage un
plan triénal de développement des soins
palliatifs et des unités de soins
palliatifs dont un des axes majeurs sera
la réduction des inégalités sur le
territoire et pas simplement entre les
territoires lorsqualain cl et moi-même
avons remis le Rapport au Président de
la République sur la proposition de loi
nous avons dit tous les deux que la
priorité des priorités c'était le
développement des soins palliatifs et la
formation des soignants et qu'aucune loi
si parfaite soit-elle et celle-là est
imparfaite comme toutes les lois
humaines et bien ne peut être efficace
s'il y a pas ces deux
éléments fin de l'examen du texte au
Sénat et fin de partie pour les
rapporteurs et le gouvernement qui
sortent grand perdant de cette séquence
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que le
travail qui avait été fait par nos trois
rapporteurs était un travail excellent
et que ce travail a été détricoté et si
c'était pour en arrivé à la rédaction
qui ce soir se trouve sur la table il
n'était pas nécessaire de proposer un
texte de loi
nouveau des rapporteurs déçus qui
estiment leur travail gâché par quelques
sénateurs qu'il qualifie de conservateur
c'est un texte de de
conservateur peut-être guidé aussi par
des des des des
arrièrespensées religieuses quelque peu
intégriste he j'ai j'ai pas peur de de
le dire et je trouve que allez je me
lâche la charité chrétienne c'est pas ça
si on commence à s'invectié pour dire il
y a les parce que derrière le mot
conservatoire en France c'est pour dire
voilà il mérite pas d'exister c'est
c'est faut pas s'attarder sont des
réactionnaires vous savez la réaction où
est-elle je ne traite
personne avec des qualificatifs qui
pourraient être péjoratifs ou qui
pourrai déclasser leurs arguments je
pense que l'honneur de ce genre de débat
c'est que chacun puisse essayer
d'argumenter sur ses convictions
oui
oui quelques jours plus tard à
l'occasion du vote solennel sur
l'ensemble du texte les rapporteurs
prennent le revanche le texte vidé de sa
substance article par article est
finalement rejeté par le Sénat j'ai à la
fois d'infinis regret qu'un consensus
qu'un rassemblement ne se soit pas opéré
au Sénat comme il s'était opéré à
l'Assemblée nationale mais je suis
soulagé que la sagesse de la Haute
Assemblée l''est amené à rejeter ce
texte ce qui va permettre au travail de
reprendre dans des conditions plus
simples à l'Assemblée
nationale au jeu des affrontements le
Sénat sort perdant en rejetant la
proposition de loi sur la fin de vie
dans quelques mois les députés
reprendront l'examen du texte en seconde
lecture dans sa version
initiale